thanks for that great introduction um
yeah so funny story I was here basically
a year ago and so a lot of what I'm
gonna be talking about today has to do
with work that I started actually as a
postdoc here in the vision and learning
lab um so to modify my talk I wanted to
sort of transport you to what I hope is
a familiar situation for you say that
you're in a city in this case New York
City and you're going just from one
place to another okay
and as you're basically walking by I
want you to think about all the things
that you're doing to actually get to
that place isn't it amazing how we
reason about space how we you know
figure out the general direction we want
to go we take advantage of our visual
stimuli in particular to avoid obstacles
both dynamic and static and even more we
reason about interactions that are
happening nearby and obviously we're not
just taking this early the shortest path
unless we're really in a hurry
we're actually becoming part of the
social fabric of that particular
environment and so this sort of set of
problems that I just described that we
pretty much solve without thinking about
it is something that has happened has
fascinated for a while the robotics and
the human robot interaction community
and the good news is that well we've
come very very far along in terms of
creating systems that we can deploy in
particular applications maybe in the
case of manufacturing or delivery or
even in the case of transportation and
so for many of you today especially here
in the Bay Area it might seem like
navigation may be a salt problem but the
reality that if you keep reading the
news well they're still very important
challenges that remain and I argue that
a lot of these challenges come because
of the complexity of unstructured
environments as soon as you put this
machine somewhere where you haven't
really done a lot of testing where you
don't know exactly how people will
behave then things start to break down
and so today what I'm going to do is I'm
going to present to you a couple of
different projects all of them sort of
surrounding surrounding the idea that
structure approaches approaches the sort
of like in a classical systems
engineering even in a classical robotics
way decompose a big challenge into
smaller simpler subproblems
they can help us Rison about space and
in particular the the sort of
commonality among these these methods
I'm going to be describing is that they
only use data-driven methods in
particularly deep learning in order to
do complex function approximation and
what do I mean by this what do you mean
by complex function approximation so in
the world there's lots of physical and
social things that are happening around
us we can use deep learning as a
mechanism to approximate this phenomenon
and then hopefully take advantage of
that both for perception and
decision-making in the case of human
robot interaction and even more broadly
in the case of HCI and so what I'm going
to be talking about exactly today so
those three projects on the Left I'm
going to start with what I consider to
be one of the simplest and more
important challenges which is
reversibility estimation especially for
avoiding getting your robot into
troublesome situations and then I'll
start talking about traumas are in a way
a higher-level reasoning more related to
interaction including navigation and
reasoning about spatial behavior that
might happen during social conversations
and then finally I'll talk about some
future directions both things that I
think are important that we need to
solve but also some exciting questions
in relation to social influence all
right so how many of you have heard
about reversibility estimation before
one all right so for those of you who
have never heard about this the question
here is is this place in front of the
robot safe for it to traverse or not
right very simple binary question and
you know when you can think about it as
a software solution to an emergency stop
right whenever you might see say the
jackrabbit project that I was working on
before here at Stanford you might see
someone behind the robot with ready to
press a button right that looks like
whoo I'm gonna stop the robot this is
basically an alternative or a
complementary solution to do that
through software and so in this
particular project what we were trying
to do was answer this question based on
an image in particular an image capture
from a camera with a fisheye lens that
has a wide view of the environment and
based on that image then we wanted to
say okay what is the probability that
the environment scene
that image is safe for the robot to
traverse here the assumption is that
that camera is on the robot and that's
basically what's going to come up in
front of the robot the next time now
from this image this might seem like a
very simple problem right we just have
to look for kind of empty hallways but
even if you go and collect data for this
problem here at Stanford then you still
realize there are lots of different
scenarios that might come up that may
pose challenges and so what makes it
this even harder is that this
challenging is scenarios are the ones
that you actually don't want to expose
your robot to because probably is gonna
be in trouble very soon after it since
these images right and so because of
that what you end up having when you try
to apply machine learning to this
problem is an uneven distribution of
lots of positive examples things that
are safe for the robot to see which you
can easily collect and just a few
negative examples of things that you
were willing to expose your robot to to
get at least some negative data of what
might be trouble sourcing circumstances
and so this is an even distribution
naturally is a problem for standard
supervised learning methods and what we
do in this case is treated as an anomaly
detection problem or go here for
Traverse ability estimation is estimate
detect these images whenever they come
in the view of the robot so that it
doesn't hopefully collide or fall down
the stairs whatever that is now how do
we implement this so the method that we
propose is called Gonet it takes us
input an image of the environment as you
saw before and then internally is going
to generate an image that looks like the
input but that also is constrained to
look traversable okay how do we do this
so have you ever heard about generative
adversarial networks before raise your
hand yeah so I don't even have to
explain this so what's happening here is
we have lots of positive examples right
we can use a gun to train a generator
function that given some noise input
will give us an image that looks like a
positive example right but then in order
to make this image that is being
generated similar to the input then we
also train an inverse generator function
once the generator is fixed in order to
find what
should be the noise that we pass to the
generator so that we get something that
looks similar to the input okay what
does this mean in practice well if your
input is actually traversable then the
two images will look similar but if your
input is not then the two images will
look more different because the images
are clones trying to look as if they
were traversable and so based on that we
can use very simple features even like
the difference between the images pixel
wise in order to finally classify
whether the input image is traversable
or not here using a small set of
positive and negative examples and so
why does this work well this process in
a way is sort of rejecting the input
space into space that hopefully is
easier to classify based on these
features okay you can think about it
that way now here's an example of how
this looks in a video so what you're
gonna see on the left is the input image
captured from a robot on the right you
have the predicted image and then in the
bottom you have the probability that
that space is traversable as the robot
starts is in front of an open hallway so
the two images look more similar what's
gonna happen next is that the Robo is
gonna turn towards the elevator pay
attention there because then the images
will change a lot okay so now something
boom the elevator disappears it looks
like a hallway again and even the person
that you're gonna see here also becomes
sort of static element and it's not
until the robot goes back into the
hallway that images look more similar
that's one actually helps detect
reversibility okay you can see even the
paintings in the walls disappear because
they're not coming across the data set
right paintings might be specific to
specific places now um the original
method that we designed here it assumed
that all the images are independent you
know every time you get an image you run
your your particular method and you get
a prediction but this is of course not
true for images captured by a robot
because well the images are going to be
correlated across time and you actually
have video and so in order to account
for this what we did was we added a
recurring neural network to the method
in order to enforce temporal consistency
of predictions the other thing that we
tried was actually adding too
cameras to the robot and here the
hypothesis was well we have two views
hopefully we can detect the differences
between the views and this will give us
a hint as to whether things that
perceptually look as if it was
reversible but actually look differently
two cameras are at a given distance from
the robot so this is basically trying to
use implicitly disparity among the
images to try to predict reversibility
and so here you have some quantitative
results on a data set that was collected
at Stanford Business any future is
actually available online so if you
google Bonett you'll get access to all
of the data if you want to play with it
what we're comparing against here is
having a Kinect on the robot which is
sort of the standard approach that you
might use if you have the type of robot
that we had before the Kinect is nice
because it has a depth image that
already tells you an information about
how far things are then the second
method here this time is network is
basically state-of-the-art features for
object detection and now assemble for
the two images together in order to
predict reversibility and then you have
the basic version of Gonet the one with
temporal consistency and then the one
that uses the the two views and so in
general going it to perform really well
what was surprising to me though is that
here the Kinect did not perform better
and I think this has a lot to do with
the type of images that we were using
which have a very wild field of view
versus the Kinect which has also a way
narrow field of view and as well
sometimes the noise in the depth of that
sensor is pretty noisy yeah and yes they
probably complement each other so I
would not say you know you should remove
all of your lighters and depth sensors
from your robots and then put this on I
would not recommend that at all I would
say probably you want to have this as an
additional source of information all
right so let me show you some examples
here actually in this building so this
is the robot that in this case an
operator is controlling and what the
operator is doing is basically sending
velocity commands to the robot and
internally we're using Gonet to stop
linear velocity commands that will keep
moving the robot forward whenever the
probability of traverse ability goes
and so in this particular case the
operator is kind of telling the robot to
go against the glass wall and if you see
that red tape here this is because we're
using only one camera sometimes you'll
see a video with the two cameras and
those those are actually the fish our
view is that then you saw before so that
stop was actually going now you might
wonder well how can this do this if this
is actually glass right sometimes we
even bump into glass and so my my hint
here is that actually this line on the
ground is is very informative for what's
happening here's another example now
here we're using the two cameras you can
see the operator on the right so we did
a bunch of experiments where we just
threw things in front of the robot
trying to see would stop not everything
is perfect though for instance in this
case it stops there is that piece of
cable under the road which you could
claim it's a problem so anything that is
really small anything that looks very
similar to the ground of course because
of visual features can be an issue so
that's why I was saying probably it's
good that you complement this with other
approaches now the fun experiment here
is that all the data we use to train
this method was collected indoors and at
some point the the first authors of this
paper they decided to try out well what
happens if we actually run it outdoors
um and so what happened here was we have
a person
this is noriaki first author of the
paper he is holding now the fisheye
camera as if he was a robot he is also
blindfolded and holding the laptop in a
backpack and then what we did was we
connected the output of gonna to a voice
alert so that whenever the Traverse
ability estimation went down the
probability went down then the system
you know and advised the user so let me
show you how this looked in this case
now this is surprising that it works at
all we've ever worked in in deep
learning because there were no images
outdoors in the data set that we were
using and so in a way this was actually
very very telling for us that this
method has potential to generalize to
new situations than what he has seen
before all right so that's my story
about reversibility estimation I'm now
going to switch gears to say now that
you can stop moving and start thinking
about how to get to a place this is what
we normally called
a be navigation and I'm saying here this
is social because we not only care about
getting to that destination but we care
about getting there in a way that
hopefully feels appropriate for the
people nearby in a way that you know we
considered to be socially acceptable and
so for this work
the main assumptions are that one we
have a map of the environment okay so we
don't have to solve mapping we also can
localize the robot so that we know given
that map where it is at any given time
and we can also detect people and track
them and that tells us relative to the
robot where individuals that might
matter for the navigation task now if
you were to implement this with sort of
a regular system this is what it might
look like this is a hierarchical
controller where you would have a global
planner that takes that map the goal
where you want to go and your current
location and say okay this is general
direction that you want to follow and
then you will have a reactive controller
that would take sensor data and then
predict velocities both linear and
angular velocity to adapt to the things
that were not in your map to the things
are dynamic in the environment and so in
practice this looks something like this
so say this is your robot and then here
all the green lines are lighter returns
so you have a sensor that measures
distance and based on where the robot is
and whatever this sensor says then you
can start computing costs for your
environment that allows that reactive
controller to basically figure out how
you should move around the environment
to not collide with all of these
different elements if you have something
like in person you might assign special
class to it to for instance model
personal space even model interactions
if you know that people are coming
together
and so on now what is the challenge of
these approaches well it turns out that
depending where you want to run your
robot depending on the type of social
context you might want to set different
costs for the things in your environment
and there might be a lot of hyper
parameter tuning that you have to do in
order to find what is the right set of
costs that will give you the behavior
that you actually want at the end of the
day and so because of all that tuning
that has to go on recent methods have
started to look at implementing that
reactive controller now using machine
learning right the hope is that well we
can now optimize for what those
parameters should be as a function of
where the robot wants to go and sensor
data and in general if you do this would
say imitation learning the other
assumption is that the example data that
you have it encodes what it means for
the robot to navigate appropriately and
that also saves us from actually having
to explicitly write down what it means
for the robot to navigate in a good way
based on on people's opinions now
remember this is a big assumption so
ultimately we always want to test after
the fact with people to check if what is
happening kind of makes sense and so
what we're doing is work is take a
similar approach to this but we add a
structure to this problem such then one
we can have a little bit more
interpretability as to what's happening
under the hood and second hopefully we
get to a better behavior than you would
get with just a black box um and so in
this case what we have is a local
planner that will predict a modification
to the global plan this is what we call
the local plan and that's going to adapt
again to the dynamics of the environment
and then we're going to have a velocity
controller that takes that local plan
information F G here is features from
the global plan and information from the
sensors here this is lighter information
to then output velocity commands for the
robot and so how does that look in
practice here is a video of a simulation
we have pedestrian simulated pedestrians
moving around we have static obstacles
we have a role that we want the robot to
reach and a global plan that was
computed based on the map of the
environment now that this global plan is
not ideal because it's actually coming
very close to a person in that point but
that person is not in the map so there's
no way
the high-level planner knows that and
then what the robot has to do is predict
based on all that information what
velocities it should actually execute in
order to get to the destination now our
approach also outputs this predicted
local plan which is a visualization in a
way of how the robot is going to be
moving in the environment it doesn't
have to follow it perfectly but it kind
of hints to you how the robot is going
to go about what's seeing at that point
so if things are going well you should
see that local plan sort of adapting to
the dynamic elements and eventually when
the robot that reaches to go police
stops stops and and it reach the
destination now one of the challenges
when we were working on this problem
that came about I think this is a common
challenge in general in HCI as soon as
you start working with many different
types of sensor data is how should we
combine all the information that is
coming in into our modules here about
the local planner and the velocity
controller and sort of the standard
thing that you might do is just
concatenate all the features together
into a bigger feature vector and then
process that along now what happened in
our case is that we just did this the
robot would pay attention to one thing
more than the other and so we said ah
let's be smart let's add more features
for the things that is not paying
attention to and they would actually pay
a lot of attention to those things and
not the other things that it was paying
attention to originally and so because
of that we decided to go with sort of a
dynamic set of combination for these
features what we're doing is computing
attention coefficients for each of them
as a function of what their values are
and in this way based on whatever the
context is where the robot is navigating
it would basically scale some features
more than the others to pay more
attention to that particular source
information so let me show you here how
this looks so this is a plot for the
inputs to the velocity controller and
then on the y-axis you have that
attention coefficient for each of them
when the robot starts moving when it's
close to a dynamic element the ladder
becomes more important as the robot
starts basically moving around free
space than the local plan what it has to
follow becomes more relevant and then at
the end when it starts approaching the
global plan then the global plan the the
end destination in the global plan
comes more relevant as it was nice to
see right even though we were not
supervising these attention coefficients
this is something that could be learned
from data based on how the example
trajectories that we had to train this
model look like now we compare this
method against other approaches in
particular sort of a classical approach
like the one that I described before
where you Huntoon the costs for things
in your environment and also to deep
learning methods that kind of work as a
black box the first one here just takes
one point along the high-level plan that
robot has and this point is at a fixed
trajectory at a fixed distance from the
robot and then the one over here
actually takes a sequence of points from
where the robot is up to a given
distance and then we compare that with
our proposed approach here's an example
um video of all of these methods running
in practice what you see is that in
general our approach is not necessarily
the most efficient but it definitely can
handle sort of variations in the
locality of the robot and it can adjust
the things that are happening by that
we're not this is not really part of the
plan in this particular case these two
other deep learning methods kind of got
stuck this doesn't happen all the time
this is just one example but what you
can see is for instance here even even
this was troublesome because the robot
came very close to a person there what
you can see is that in general this is a
very complex problem and part of what
makes it successful for a robot to to do
a good job here has to do with that
spatial reasoning that we normally do
without even thinking about it
so quantitatively how did this method do
so what we have here are four different
environments where we tested how I was
doing this is an environment that was
very similar to the training data and so
we would expect if we're doing things
right that these numbers will all be
high even the parameters that we set for
the navigation stack were chosen based
on this particular environment now if
you go to a simpler environment where
you have fewer obstacles fewer people
same layout then most methods perform
better are a little bit down but when
you keep increasing the complexity of
the environments you either add more
people or you move to a new layout
that's where actually
benefits I think of machine learning
start showing up and the particular
structure that we gave to this problem
this I must say this is in terms of how
often the the robot reach tickle on a
number of trials that's what this plot
is showing now in this case we were
looking at how after me the robot come
close to almost or near by a collision
including collisions I'm here the
threshold for concern in near collision
was 0.3 meters and what you can see is
that in general the navigation stack is
sort of the most conservative of all
with our method being the most
conservative out of the ones that are
used in deep learning in this case now
as I said before it's important that we
understand if the end resolver if the
behaviors that were rendering kind of
makes sense to people so the first time
that we did here was actually evaluate
this perception using mechanical trick
and for that we showed 12 different
scenarios with these four methods two
people in particular we had 30 by 35
people evaluated all of these methods
what we found in this case was that in
general the approaches were considered
to be natural with the one of the black
box the learning methods mean the most
unnatural system one actually had a
trajectory as input we also found that
methods tend to not be considered an
aggressive note that this is evaluating
videos right so it's not 100% telling
you the full story but at least it was
good to see that is these numbers were
low and also we found that our
particular approach was considered to be
efficient more efficient in comparison
to other methods these two differences
were marginally significant and this to
me actually was surprising because when
you look at the method is really not
rendering sort of the the minimum path
but it seems like the way that is
adapting to the environment people
consider it to be more efficient than
the other approaches now how long does
this transfer to the real world
well we don't know yet we're trying to
answer that question this is a very very
early video of the robot executing the
policy that we train his simulation it's
not perfect but at least we're starting
to see cases where hopefully we can run
this on the real robot which is in
general a hard thing to do in robotics
because transferring from simulation to
to real world is difficult because of
the differences in the input
distributions one
biggest challenges here I must say is
actually people tracking which is not as
consistent as it obviously happened in
simulation and so now you see this robot
around be careful because we might be
testing you know the new approaches that
we're implementing on it don't assume
that the robot works perfectly which
many people sort of do all right now I'm
moving on I want to talk about an even
higher level sort of sort of reasoning
problems which have to do with
understanding human spatial behavior for
the purposes of of interacting and this
problem this is something that I started
working on while I was a PhD student I
was working here with Disney and we had
made this furniture robot that we wanted
to show two groups of kids that came to
to the laboratory and so the whole setup
was as follows so people came to the
laboratory they start interacting with
the robot they didn't know I was gonna
be there and sort of the storyline of
the interaction build up to a point
where the robot gave them a set of
souvenirs for having come to the lab and
then soon after after they got this
piece of paper that you see here crazy
things happen people did not pay
attention to the robot anymore you know
the members of the conversations change
even more new conversations started
right in front of the robot even though
it was still speaking and trying to
engage the children in that environment
and so when this happened we kept
wondering right why can't we do in order
to enable robots to understand that
these interacting groups are actually
changing right in front of it and you
know it might be that the environment is
noisy but it's very clear for us even
from these pictures that these groups
are changing right and so now the the
interesting bit here is that as we were
watching videos special arrangements
kept emerging like very regular special
arrangements like side-to-side or
face-to-face or circular arrangements
whenever these conversations were
happening and turns out this should not
be a surprise there's lots of work in
social psychology that described the way
that we position ourselves relative to
one another during these social
interactions what we try to do in
general is maximize our opportunities to
monitor one another mutual perceptions
and this naturally results in these
types of formations
how does this work in practice so we all
have what is known as a transactional
segment that is used these space that
extends forward from our body that
includes whatever we're engaged with and
whenever we hold conversations we
naturally position energy orient
ourselves so that we intersect our
transactional segments with one another
and that way we have equal direct and
exclusive access to the space between us
and that's what leads to all these
different kinds of formations that I
assume you're very familiar with now a
lot of my work in my PhD focus on very
very finely hypothesis that this also
happens in human robot interaction and
in fact we try this basically in the
experiment that I showed you originally
also in a case where the robot was
playing mafia with groups of people and
also in another experiment where people
were brainstorming ideas with the robot
in all these cases these types of
formations tended to emerge and so then
the question became how can we recognize
these formations automatically using
computational methods and at the time
the way that we propose to do that is as
follows we had information about the
position of people in the scene
information about their lower body
orientation which is sort of the main
feature that matters for transactional
segments and then we modeled those
spaces we try to find whatever the
transactional segments of people
intersected and then we say ah-ha there
is a no space there's probably a group
going on now the twist here is that you
can also use information about the
groups that are happening at any point
in time in order to better estimate
people's orientation and the reason why
this happens is because interactions are
naturally a forest that biases the way
that people stand in human environments
right if I were standing here all the
time giving my back to you probably you
wouldn't feel so comfortable with all
the information that I'm saying because
it would not be clear if I'm actually
talking to you at this time and so we
use this particular method in order to
study body orientation and gaze here in
this particular case we had the robot
basically orient in two different ways
this is a between subject experiment in
one case the robot oriented towards the
middle of its conversational group as
computer automatically by the method and
in our case it turned towards the person
who was the speaker or the addressee at
that given time and then we also had the
robot change its gaze during the
interaction and basically we have here
four conditions combining each of these
variables what we found in this case is
that in general when things went wrong
this completely disrupted the
interaction right people wouldn't know
what what is going on and so it's
actually very important for robots to
conform to the way that people expect
them to be positioning themselves in
these environments the other thing that
was interesting was that the particular
gage behavior that we tried influenced
the perception of the robot's motion and
vice versa and the motion that the robot
was executing whether it was orienting
towards the middle or it was the
attentive orientation behavior it
influenced the perception that people
had of the gaze of the robot and because
of this even though often we designed
this behaviour independently of each
other I think that we should rather try
to do it gently in order to account for
these potential effects of one into the
other now at the time a lot of the
experiments that I did were were simple
open spaces and if you look around right
there's many environments where the the
type of formations that you see they're
actually malleable to to that context
right if you enter for instance an
elevator people might be okay kind of
coming closer to one another because
well obviously the space is more
constrained similarly if you're in a
party where there's lots of people
around you might actually change the
distance is in your proxemics behavior
based on what's going on and so because
of that then we decided to try in this
case again there are driven methods and
now reframe the problem as a clustering
problem from a certain more classical
perspective so here say that you have a
scene right of people interacting then
you can build a graph where every node
corresponds to a person and then the
engines if they have a weight that way
corresponds to how likely it is that
people are actually part of the same
conversation and so provided you have
some algorithm to do graph clustering
which which exists for the case of
conversational groups then the question
that remains is what should be the
weights Nia finish then you assign to
those edges in the graph so then you end
up having a good result when you try to
cluster people out right and so for that
what we did was we proposed to use a
neural network again because he has
great approximation capabilities in this
case for this type of social phenomena
and so the way the system works is we
haven't seen put a social scene for
which we have position and orientation
for everybody in that scene then we
build a graph that I mentioned before
and then for every edge we're going to
compute an affinity value that depends
on features of the diet that we care
about which are just the nodes related
to that edge
but also on features of all the other
people in this scene if this scene was
very big then you would just pick the
people nearby the edge that you care
about and so how does this two
transforms look like they actually look
very similar and what we have as input
is information about the position and
the orientation of people here this is
for numbers just because we are encoding
the orientation with cosine and sine and
then the other two numbers are just X
and y and then we pass this through a
transformation it gives us features in a
higher dimensional space and then we use
a symmetric function here in the same
spirit of Poynette and which was used to
reason about point clouds in order to
get one feature that is the relevant of
the order of the inputs so in this
particular case is a magical operation
you can use another symmetric operation
potentially ok any questions about this
now right now once we have all those
Affinia is what we can do is we run our
clustering algorithm here in particular
we use an algorithm called dominant sets
which is actually a generalization of
maximal cliques for weighted graphs now
what kind of results do we get in this
case so these are two data sets for
group detection within the computer
vision community the first graph here
the first blue bar corresponds to a deep
learning method that was proposed very
recently this green bar actually
corresponds to another algorithm that is
similarly reasoning about graphs
clustering and then the yellow one is
actually state-of-the-art in this
particular two data sets now for two
years or so
and so for the coffee break data set we
do as well as state of the art the
challenge here is that this dataset has
orientations for people that are bent
into four possible numbers and that
makes it actually really hard to notice
small variations in people orientation
now in the cocktail party data set where
the orientation is actually way way more
fine-grained then in this case we
actually outperform the state of the art
and the nice thing I think of this
approach which which makes it very very
straightforward to implement is that
again we're not finding all the
parameters of what exactly should be the
transactional segment for every people
in the scene which is some of the things
that you have to care about for graph
codes approach all right so for the
remaining time that I have ten minutes
or so I want to talk about some future
research directions which I think we're
now going to be able to avoid and others
that I just think are interesting and
fun to think about
so one question that often people ask
especially within human robot
interaction and I think it's yeah as
well is why are we using neural networks
and I my answer to this is that well if
you look at how well they perform
against other learning algorithms there
has been a clear advantage and we want
to take advantage of that sort of
powerful capabilities of these methods
the challenge here though is that for
most problems that have to do with
interaction you're actually in this
space where you don't have that much
data and so a natural question arises of
how do we get more data right so that we
can actually take advantage of these
methods for for what we want to do for
the case of navigation and and in
particular for the case of robotics I'm
a big advocate for just getting data
from the real world I know this is very
expensive but I think it's going to be
very fruitful in the long term so that's
one of the things that we're exploring
in particular in the jackrabbit project
here at Stanford another thing that you
might want to do is actually take
advantage of simulations simulations of
course are not gonna be perfect even
when you think about simulating a person
that's very challenging on itself but it
might actually allow you to make
progress faster and prototype algorithm
in a way that hopefully doesn't take
forever for you to get an answer of how
well things are working this particular
type of simulation environments here
we're using unity I think there's lots
of potential for using all of the
different game engines that are coming
along that are becoming available now
for this kind of work one of the also
interesting positive things of these
environments is that you can very easily
export your games into online form which
means that you can potentially engage a
bigger amount of people than if you had
to bring everybody to your lab to try
out your environment and then basically
use it in person now in terms of sample
efficient methods I think there's also
very interesting potential for
revisiting ideas from topological
navigation for the case of enabling
robots to move around human environments
and so when I when I'm saying here
topological navigation this is what I
mean so say the robot wants to go from
one place to another sort of us as we
want it before but now instead of
modeling the environment precisely with
a metric map that's kind of what we were
assuming we had in the in the prior
example we're gonna have a graph and
this graph is going to now be a more
compact representation of that space
here the nodes correspond to places
where it's sort of a critical situation
where you want to make potentially a
change in decision in terms of where
you're going so think about it like
entry ways or exit ways from from other
places even points along a corridor
whenever you can change the direction
one way or another and then the engines
in this particular case encode
connectivity that's sort of the
classical view of topological navigation
now in this particular case the twist of
how we're thinking about this taken
advantage of data-driven methods is that
each of these edges can also correspond
to a particular behavior that the robot
can execute to go from the source node
to the target node and if you think
about in their environments there's
often lots of things that you do that
look very very similar to each other
right and so you can potentially have
just a small set of behaviors like the
ones that you see here that you can then
compose with one another in order to get
basically a complex now
en route and so here for instance we
have we're considering turning left
behaviors turning right
following a corridor finding a door and
moving straight now with this five said
five behaviors that you see here we can
now enable a robot to go from that upper
room over there
all the way to this room simply by
localizing relative to the graph in this
particular case using graph neural
networks and then executing depending on
the edge that you're in the graph that
particular visual motor behavior that is
a deep learning policy for the robot now
note here that the robot is not using
this map it's just taken as input this
depth image from the environment and the
particular behavior that it has to
execute and that allows the robot to
navigate all the way around to the
destination now this word gear does not
consider dynamic elements this is all in
a static environment but I think if we
start thinking about how are we gonna
make robots really operating human
environments where everybody's going
around every time I go to New York City
I go to the subway and I see how crazy
it is how people are moving I think this
type of approaches have slightly better
chance than if we assume we're going to
have a perfect map metric map of the
environment where we're always gonna
know precisely where we are because
often right all the people around you
will look good could you now another
sort of positive aspect of this type of
work is that the semantics of this
behaviour can make an easy connection to
natural language directions and so we've
also explore taking natural language
directions and then translating them to
a sequence of behaviors using in this
case the topological graph basically as
as a database or a knowledge base for
this translation task all right now in
terms of thinking more about kind of
classical human robot interaction
problems one issue that arises very
often when you put a robot in a public
space is the following so this is a
robot in Japan this is super Bobby and
the robot is in a mall and when kids
find it they start doing all sorts of
crazy things to the robot and so one of
the strategies in this work
to help the robot was to actually have
it move whenever you can move towards
the parents of the kids because then you
know the the kids will behave a little
bit better and so this line of work is
actually very interesting right because
it poses the question of how can robots
take advantage of their social context
in order to help themselves in these
these kinds of settings and so to
explore this question we decided to run
a lab experiment where we had a
Confederate here the person on the Left
interact with the participant which is
see on the right and these two people
they were said to complete a distraction
test mainly a memorization test here on
the tablet and while they were doing
that there was a robot nearby that
happened to be there because they were
using him before for something else and
the Confederate would fail at the task
and then basically release its anger
with the robot and then the question was
how should the robot behave in order to
motivate this person to help you out
even a little bit okay so let me show
you an example of what what this abuse
looked like this was both verbal and
physical abuse
starting with verbal abuse and then
combining verbal and physical this is
sort of like the worst case scenario at
the end of this session so this is the
robot that you see there and so a lot of
people were in shock no surprise in
terms of what the robot tried to do so
in one case this is one of the variables
we manipulator which was the response
from the robot in West Gaines the robot
did absolutely nothing right it was
abuse and it just kept doing whatever he
was supposed to do in another case in
the shutdown response condition it just
kind of showed a sad face for a little
bit and then he shut down for 10 seconds
and then went back up and then kept
doing whatever he was doing and then in
the emotional response condition the
robot first became sad and then angry
and the Confederate now the other thing
that we manipulated was empathy whether
the robot was empathetic to the task
that people were doing how well they
were doing in it and whether it was just
indifferent right he didn't care what
was happening well we found in this case
was that even though respect any
empathetic
- in general induce more helping
behavior there was no difference across
conditions and the majority of the
people ended up helping the robot and so
this is actually good news for Humanity
I think I'm not for experiment
necessarily because the results were not
as significant but I think it's good
that people were actually at the end at
least flipping up the robot or even
sometimes moving away from the
Confederates that hopefully would not
abuse it again now in terms of the
responses that the robot had in general
the shutdown response was the one that
led to higher ratings of the perception
of the verbal abuse and also higher
distress from the participants and so in
a way it seemed like they this shutdown
response ended up being sort of the more
effective out of the ones that we tried
now this is just a very small baby step
I think it's important to for us to
think about this question right how can
robots motivate pro-social human
behavior and potentially right if they
could do this then you can imagine that
robots could leverage their social
context for practical problems like the
one that I that I showed before but
maybe they could also potentially just
positively impact interactions more than
that we could ever imagine from the
beginning and so with that I'm going to
end thanking everybody that has helped
on on the many projects that I showed
before especially this time for vision
and learning lab there was a lot of a
friend bridge that I showed from the lab
and also our funding sources to your NSF
and Disney and I'll open up for
questions thank you
[Applause]